con excepción de costa rica- la región
de centroamérica como un bloque es la
más insufrible para ejercer la profesión
del periodismo en américa latina' de
estos países el peor rankeado por el
informe hoy de reporteros sin fronteras
es honduras en la plaza 165 donde antes
de que llegara xiomara castro al poder
existía la denominada ley de secreto con
la cual el ex presidente juan orlando
hernández ya ha extraditado a los
estados unidos bloqueó por años a los
periodistas el acceso a la información
del gobierno por considerarla secreto
honduras junto con guatemala ya
registran el asesinato de dos
periodistas en américa de acuerdo con la
información de la sociedad
interamericana de prensa claro está que
la mayoría de los homicidios han
ocurrido en méxico donde la profesión se
vuelve más peligrosa por el cubrimiento
de los carteles del narcotráfico sin
embargo el país que más descendió
escaños fue nicaragua llegó al puesto
160 bajo 39 escaños entendiéndolo por el
contexto de las elecciones generales que
llevaron a daniel ortega a ser reelegido
mandatario quien además de haberse
quitado del camino a otros adversarios
políticos en prisión a periodistas y
directores de medios y finalmente el
salvador bajo 30 puestos se ubica ahora
en el 112 en gran parte por las
denuncias de periodistas de la
persecución que tienen del gobierno en
allí bukele como es el caso del diario
'el faro' el director quien acusa al
presidente de perseguirlos y por tanto
de a buscarlos a un éxodo silencioso